today on the mat wall show Democrats in
the Senate sign religious Liberty's
death warrant with 12 Republicans
obediently going along with it also
Disney Retreats from the culture War New
York City pledges to start getting
violent crazy people off the streets
there's an idea Will Smith begins his
Redemption toward just in time for his
new movie and the U.S men's team wins a
big cash prize for its recent victory at
the World Cup and now they have to split
it with the women's Team all in the name
of equality all of that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
if you're listening to this show odds
are that you put a lot of stock into how
you raise your kids you understand that
your children look to you to Define
their values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property it lays out
your health care power of attorney to
ensure that your end of life decisions
are carried out so if you're just
starting out and you don't have
thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you want to make sure your
savings your belongings and your family
are all protected you have to create
your will at epicwill.com today epic
Will's early estate plans started just
119 and you can save 10 percent when you
use promo code walls go to epicwill.com
use promo code walls to save 10 on Epic
Wheels complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Welsh
yesterday was we're told an historic day
in the U.S Senate a landmark occasion
with 61 votes including every Democrat
plus 12 obsequious pathetic like spittle
Republicans the Senate officially passed
the ineptly named respect for Marriage
Act and the bill will of course repeal
the Defense of Marriage Act codify gay
marriage into law at the federal level
officially redefining marriage and
reshaping it in the image of left-wing
ideology and despite assurances from the
aforementioned obsequious pathetic licks
bittles it will in fact set the stage
for an all-out assault on religious
liberty across the entire country now
there can only be two reasons for
legislation like this to be introduced
in the first place and that's one of
them to destroy religious liberty it's
why Democrats were celebrating the bill
as a consequential moment in American
history here's senator Tammy Baldwin
yesterday afternoon after the bill was
passed talking about how historic it all
is
you know a lot of people have asked me
in recent days what the passage of this
historic bill would mean to me as a
member of the lgbtq plus community
what I said to people who asked me a
similar question back in 2012 when I was
first elected to the United States
Senate still Rings true today
I didn't run for the Senate to make
history I ran for the Senate to make a
difference and we are not pushing this
legislation to make history we are doing
this to make a difference for Millions
upon millions of Americans
it's a historic day
sorry I should have specified Tammy
Baldwin actually argues that the bill
does not make history but it is historic
what what exactly is the distinction
here this is like the greatest humble
brag I've ever heard you should try that
in a job interview maybe you know I'm uh
I'm not interested in making history I
just want to make a difference
what actually what is what's the
difference between making history and
being historic there really isn't one
but Democrats are simply determined to
never speak clearly about anything they
are allergic to Clarity it would seem
and yet in spite of the obfuscation it's
clear what is actually happening here as
I said there are only two reasons why
this bill was written introduced and now
passed and will certainly be signed by
uh by Biden the first reason is to
Virtue signal you know and to give
Democrats something to do that doesn't
involve solving any of the many actual
problems that we face as a country this
is reason enough to oppose the bill also
and it ought to have been reason enough
for every Republican to vote against it
because even if you agree with the
Democrats on the subject of marriage you
should still see this bill at the very
best as in some ways similar to say the
anti-lynching law that Biden signed last
year in that case I of course agreed
with the Democrats that lynching is bad
but I opposed the law
because lynching is already illegal it's
already a felony and it's already a hate
crime so before Biden signed the bill
anyone who lynched a black person would
be certain to spend the rest of his life
in federal prison after the bill anyone
who lynches a black person is certain to
spend the rest of his life in federal
prison nothing has changed the bill was
a waste of time designed to help
generate the false impression that
Democrats in D.C are actually working to
solve problems when in fact they aren't
working on solving any real problems at
all in a similar way the so-called
respect for Marriage Act was pushed
through in response to a totally
imagined threat
the backers of the bill have imagined a
hypothetical scenario where some
undetermined
unspecified State somewhere passes a law
Banning same-sex marriage and then that
law is upheld by a federal court and
then it winds its way through the court
system and uh and ends up at our
nation's highest court where a majority
of justices side with the unknown State
and gay marriage is overturned every
part of that scenario is a fantasy no
part of it will actually happen there is
no state in the Union attempting to ban
same-sex marriage there is no federal
court that would uphold such a law and
there's only one maybe two but certainly
not a majority in the Supreme Court that
would side with the state in such a
situation anyway
so this law to begin with is not needed
and therefore again at the very best
it's designed to give Democrats an
opportunity to stand in front of the
press and congratulate themselves on a
historic victory over an imagined enemy
they are once again solving a made-up
problem because they don't have the
interest or the will or the ability to
solve any of the real problems and in
fact most of the real problems they
don't even see as problems and that's
the first problem
and that's that's issue number one here
but it's worse than that because I wish
the legislation was merely pointless I
wish that it was merely meant to Virtue
signal it was merely a waste of time but
it is in fact far more troubling than
that as it turns out the law will
accomplish something namely it will
accomplish the further destruction and
degradation of religious liberty and
Free Speech in the United States
and if you were among the oblivious
conservatives who didn't see this or
understand it before hopefully you've
now been jolted awake by the fact that
three attempts to include amendments
protecting religious liberty all failed
okay there were attempts to put
religious liberty amendments on this
thing guaranteeing that religious
liberty would not be uh this bill would
not be used to attack religious liberty
and all those amendments fail reading
from the daily wire it says Oklahoma
Republican senator James Langford who
proposed an amendment addressing
religious liberty concerns one of the
language fails to place any restrictions
which would cause entities such as
non-profits or faith-based organizations
to choose uh not to provide those
services or to abandon their faith quote
I encourage everyone in this body to ask
a very simple question to themselves is
today about respecting the rights of all
Langford said on the senate floor or is
it about silencing some Senator Mike Lee
called on his Republican colleagues in
favor of the legislation to include
protections for anyone with a religious
belief or moral conviction that marriage
belongs to one man and one woman Lee
introduced an amendment prohibiting
Federal bureaucrats from discriminating
against individuals organizations and
other religious entities by stripping
away tax-exempt status licenses
contracts or other benefits quote
instead of subjecting churches religious
nonprofits and persons of conscience to
undo scrutiny or punishment by the
federal government because of their
views on marriage we should make
explicitly clear that this legislation
does not constitute a national policy
endorsing a particular view of marriage
that threatens the tax-exempt status of
faith-based non-profits he wrote as we
move forward let us be sure to keep
churches religious Charities and
religious universities out of litigation
in the first instance
but neither Langford Lee or Senator Mark
Rubio's Amendment to the bill passed
so that tells you what you need to know
there were multiple attempts to add
specific strong clear language
guaranteeing the religious rights of
individual Americans and those attempts
were all rebuffed
here is a senator Lee explaining more
about the purpose of his Amendment
listen
in the hope that we can come to a place
where we respect each other I have
offered an amendment to this legislation
that would explicitly minimize the
threats to these religious organizations
and individuals
I'm at the table I'm willing to
compromise
and in the spirit of compromise I've
publicly stated and I reiterate here
again today
that I will support the legislation
if my amendment is adopted
my Amendment simply prohibits the
federal government from discriminating
against schools businesses and
organizations
based on their religious beliefs about
same-sex marriage
that's all it does
my Amendment prevents the Internal
Revenue Service
among other things from revoking the
tax-exempt status of these Charities and
organizations simply because they act
according to their beliefs about the
Divine Purpose of marriage
it prevents the Department of Education
from targeting schools with honor codes
based on the fact that they've got
Provisions in their own codes based on
religious beliefs
it protects individuals from being
denied business licenses or grants or
other statuses based on their views
about marriage
it protects Americans who wish to add
who wish to act according to their
religious beliefs
from being forced to abandon their
god-given mandates to love serve and
care for the poor the orphan and the
refugee
if we allow the government to threaten
their ability to do so then
the religious liberty of every American
is in peril
well that argument was not persuasive to
those assembled that Amendment failed
we're told that the Amendments weren't
needed because the so-called respect for
Marriage Act already protects religious
liberty and that of course is a lie
here's what the bill actually says on
the subject of religious liberty here's
the language in the bill it says diverse
beliefs about the role of gender in
marriage are held by reasonable and
sincere People based on decent and
honorable religious or philosophical
premises therefore Congress affirms that
such people and their diverse beliefs
are due proper respect
well that means exactly nothing
notice how it does not
spy doesn't mention uh any specific
belief about marriage it doesn't say
anything that you know belief in
traditional or biblical or man woman
marriage uh no word like that or term
like that is used
it only says that diverse beliefs are
due respect
which beliefs
and what does do respect even mean I
mean we don't need the law to Grant
vague and unspecified respect to certain
beliefs
yes people are people are free to
believe whatever they want
so when you hear from a government you
know uh from from these people oh you
could well we're not going to stop you
from believing what you want to believe
well I know that because you can't stop
me from believing something even if you
wanted to and I think you do want to
because a belief is something that I
carry around in my head and in my heart
there's no law that can govern that
directly
so the issue isn't belief per se but
action
the government must protect your right
not simply to believe what you want to
believe but to live out and act out your
faith
and this is precisely what the bill does
not protect
it's what the Amendments that were voted
down were supposed to protect
but the bill does not
also note that the supposed religious
liberty protections in the bill only
apply to religious institutions like
churches allegedly protecting their
right to not directly participate in the
solemnization of a same-sex marriage I'm
skeptical that those protections will be
meaningful in practice but they also
don't include the people who actually
need the protections as recent history
shows the left is far more interested in
imposing its will on small town Bakers
and photographers and florists who
prefer not to lend their services to gay
weddings
but a bakery is not a religious
Institution
and yet the baker still has First
Amendment rights or at least he ought to
you shouldn't need to work for a
religious institution in order to have
the right to live and operate according
to your religious beliefs
in fact if you're only allowed to live
by your religious beliefs at church
then you don't have religious liberty at
all
and that is the goal here the left's
goal is to contain religious expression
relegate it to certain assigned areas
and then once it's been entirely walled
in
that's when they set out to eradicate it
completely
this is how it has always worked
historically
and now we're seeing it play out again
now let's get to our five headlines
you know elderly people have long been
targeted by cyber thieves scammers will
claim to be Medicare Representatives
notifying their the victims of their
eligibility for additional coverage or
scammers will create fake online
storefronts designed to trick victims
into submitting their credit card
information keeping your parents or
grandparents personal information secure
online is a key component to avoiding
cyber crime it's important to understand
how cyber crime identity theft are
affecting our lives your personal
information gets exposed so often that
is dangerously easy for cyber criminals
to steal your identity protecting your
identity then can be easy with LifeLock
by Norton LifeLock detects and alerts
you to potential identity threats that
you may not be able to spot on your own
like um loans taken out in your name or
crimes committed by thieves pretending
to be you if you do become a victim of
any theft a dedicated U.S based
restoration specialist will work to fix
it for you nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions in all businesses but it's
easy to help protect yourself with
LifeLock join now and save up to 25 off
your first year at lifelock.com Walsh
that's lifelock.com Walsh for 25 off
well the uh
so-called respect for Marriage Act a
massive
defeat uh you know in the legislature at
a massive defeat culturally as well
that's that's what it is there's just no
way around it and don't listen to any
conservative who says oh it's not it's
okay it's no big deal
because these are very often the same
exact conservatives that uh every single
massive defeat conservatives have
suffered they're the ones saying it'll
be fine no it's a fine we didn't need
that anyway religious liberty what do
you need that for they said you could
still have it at church just go to
church and have all the religious
liberty you want inside those walls
until a few years from now when the
government comes along and says you know
what uh no no you know people have the
human god-given right to uh a man has a
a human right this is a basic human
right that a man has to marry another
man and who are you even in a church to
not deny someone their human rights
so that's the argument that will that we
are going to start hearing
and then when we start hearing that
argument and they actually move finally
in a really serious way against the
church just these same conservatives
again will say well it's fine anyway
it's you know used to in your home at
least
what do you need to gather together for
to express your religious Faith Can I
just stay at your home there's Zoom
church you can do it on Zoom
well now you can't you don't have access
to zoom anymore because we took that
away because it's they're not gonna let
you use it for those for those bigoted
purposes they just so just stay at your
house
gather together in your home not too
many of you just just individual
families
that's a defeat
um but there was yesterday a victory a
you know much smaller scale I have to
say but also important so Christopher
has this report it says um in recent
years the Walt Disney Company has become
embroiled in America's culture War as
I've reported the company has pushed
critical race Theory and its employee
training programs and radical gender
ideologies children's programming last
week Disney's board of directors fired
CEO Bob chapek who lost a high profile
fight with Governor Ron DeSantis
regarding legislation restricting
radical gender theory in schools and
brought back former CEO Bob Iger to
write the ship
uh roof all reports I have obtained
exclusive video of iger's first town
hall meeting with Disney employees in
which he Retreats from the company's
most controversial political positions
and moves toward neutrality in the
culture War
so I want to go through some of these
videos
um as he's talking to his employees
about his vision for Disney going
forward
um and we'll start with this here's Bob
Iger answering a question about whether
Disney will uh stay out of what's Disney
going to do about politics are they
going to stay involved in politics are
they going to get out of politics
here's what he says
this is a virtual question many cast
members had wished that Disney stayed
out of politics Will Disney stay out of
making political statements
you know I think there's a Mis
perception here about what politics is
and I think that some of the subjects
that have proven to be controversial as
it relates to Disney have been branded
political and I don't necessarily
believe they are I don't think when you
were telling stories and attempting to
be a good citizen of the world that
that's political just not how I view it
do I like the company being embroiled in
controversy of course not it can be
distracting and it can have a negative
impact on the company and to the extent
that I can work to kind of quiet things
down I'm going to do that but I think
it's it's important to put in
perspective what some of these subjects
are and not just simply brand them
political
okay so that's a little bit uh yes on
one hand he's saying we're retreating
from politics but that he does also
offer this qualification that well I
don't consider some of this stuff to be
politics uh so that's a classic that's a
a classic move on the left is to say
well this is this this isn't political
or ideological at all
right to uh to have gay romance
storylines and and films for kids
nothing ideological or political about
that
so you can't tell based on that is this
just his way of actually doubling down
and saying we're going to continue in
this direction I think it becomes more
clear when he's asked specifically about
the battle with uh with Ron DeSantis in
Florida and how he feels about that now
uh you know upon reflection here's what
he says
Bob have you ever any thoughts on how to
tackle the Reedy Creek situation in
Florida
no
um I I
um I have to get up to speed on that
completely obviously I followed the news
that development occurred after I left
the company I was sorry to see us
um uh dragged into that battle
um and I have no idea exactly what its
ramifications are in terms of the
business itself what I can say is the
state of Florida has been important to
us for a long time and we have been very
important to the State of Florida that
is something I'm extremely mindful of
and will articulate if I get the chance
but I don't have the details at all yet
about what the ramifications are of the
decision that was made by the state of
Florida and whether we intend to do
anything about it
okay and finally one of the clip to play
this is uh
more specifically asked about the don't
say gay Bill and remember this is what
this all traces back to as Disney came
out against the don't say gay Bill and
had this whole battle with DeSantis over
it uh the the
what they label the don't say gay Bill a
bill that we must remember that that
build never actually existed that was
invented by the left just to clarify uh
it was actually the anti-groomer bill
that they had a problem with but here's
what he says about that
all right another virtual question what
is your stance on the don't say gay
situation
well first of all uh
our lgbtq employees are very important
to us and we care deeply about them that
is a given
secondly this company has been telling
stories for 100 years and those stories
have had a meaningful positive impact on
the world and one of the reasons they've
had a meaningful positive impact is
because one of the core values of our
storytelling is inclusion and acceptance
and tolerance and we can't lose that we
just can't lose that and think about I
think about Black Panther and the impact
that had on the world or a film like
Coco I mean I could go on and on and how
we actually change the world for the
good must continue we also when you tell
stories it's a delicate balance you're
talking to an audience but it's also
important to listen to an audience it's
important to have respect for the people
that you're serving that you're trying
to reach and not have disdain for it
that said
we're not going to make everybody happy
all the time and we're not going to try
to and we're certainly not going to
lessen our core values in order to make
everybody happy all the time
um so it's it's complicated and there's
a balance but and I I at one point I
said we do what we believe is right and
then someone criticized them you're
saying well who are you to say that
that's right well when you're in a job
like mine or you are responsible for the
storytelling that many of you are
responsible for okay
so you want to you're talking to an
audience but you want to listen to them
and not have disdain for them that's uh
that's uh quite an interesting
Revelation don't have open contempt for
for your audience is what is what
they're realizing over at Disney or at
least is what they're saying publicly
you know gee I don't know maybe we
shouldn't be maybe we shouldn't openly
hate and we can still hate them but just
don't not let's not be so open about it
now
saw a few things about this obviously it
would be quite naive to believe that um
that this is a sign that Disney is
anti-woke now and that everything he
said about you know politics don't want
to be too involved in that they're
they're gonna withdraw completely and uh
it's gonna go back to you know they're
gonna start making
content like they made in the 1950s
right
um that's that's not going to happen I
mean Disney is run by the people it's
run by it is a it is a woke leftist
Corporation and that's probably not ever
going to change if ever did change it's
not going to happen overnight like
that's uh that's you know that's decades
long change if it ever happens at all
um
just like it took that decades for
Disney to be uh overrun by these types
of people
so it would be it would be incredibly
naive to think that that this is that
they're just you know next thing you
know Disney's like going to be modeling
itself after the daily wire that's
that's not going to happen
however
this is also a victory it's a victory
for Ron DeSantis that's for sure
he went up against Disney and this is
Disney backing down they're they're
backing away from it
which by the way if you're one of these
people that's out there claiming now
that somehow Ron DeSantis is an
establishment Republican
is completely absurd notion well this
this should put that notion to rest
okay establishment Republicans and there
are a lot of reasons why Rhonda Sanders
is not an establishment Republican okay
um but established Republicans
they're not going to go to war with
major corporations establishment
Republican who's a governor is not going
to go up against he's not going to pick
a fight with them with with the most
powerful corporate interest in his state
and if ever they establish a republican
pretends to be doing that he's going to
be the one who backs down quickly
that's that's one of the defining
features of the establishment
is that at the end of the day they are
they're going to Bow before Corporate
America and do as they're told
so this is not what the establishment
does
not just a victory for Rhonda say this
though it's also a victory this is a you
know for conservatives this is a
cultural victory
because even though Disney is not now
going to become conservative
they are actually responding to public
pressure that's what they're doing
um and now they're going to look for
more subtle ways to inject this stuff
into their programming which you could
argue is even more dangerous if they're
more subtle about it because you have to
look out for it more and that's true so
we kind of enter a new phase here
but even so they are responding to
pressure they are backing away they are
crumbling a little bit under pressure
and uh that's important
and it's important for us to see that we
can do that like we have that power
um
we can put pressure even on these major
corporations and we can force them to
respond to it
all right
from a daily wire it says New York city
mayor Eric Adams said the city will
begin to involuntary Hospital on
involuntarily hospitalize mentally ill
residents in a press conference Tuesday
Adams announced that First Responders in
the city would be able to remove people
who appear to be mentally ill and pose a
danger to themselves First Responders
will be able to remove individuals and
take them to a hospital for evaluation
and the individuals will be held until a
treatment plan is established Adam says
it's not acceptable for us to see
someone who clearly needs help and walk
past for too long there's been a gray
area where policy law and accountability
have not been clear and this has allowed
people in need to slip through the
cracks this culture of uncertainty has
led to Untold suffering and deep
frustration it cannot continue we need
to change that culture and clarify our
expectations no more walking by or
looking away no more passing the buck
going forward we will focus on action
care and compassion if severe mental
illness is causing someone to be
unsheltered and a danger to themselves
we have a moral obligation to help them
get the treatment and care they need it
begins with an immediate shift in how we
interpret Our obligation to those in
need and calls Upon Our Outreach workers
to take deeper actions and more
intensive engagement we can no longer
deny the reality that untreated
psychosis can be a cruel and
all-consuming condition that often
requires involuntary intervention
supervised medical treatment and
long-term care so there's a lot of
Revelations going on here on the left
today on one hand we've had Disney
saying maybe we shouldn't openly hate
our audience and then we've also now got
the mayor of New York saying we can't
deny reality maybe we shouldn't be
denying reality maybe to some extent we
should confront reality you know because
when there's uncomfortable realities out
there like for example the existence of
violent and dangerous crazy people it's
an uncomfortable reality but when we
just ignore it and pretend it doesn't
exist uh it just causes more suffering
for everybody involved including the
violent dangerous crazy people
so maybe we should confront that reality
and that's what they're claiming they're
going to do here now
once again on this story too I'm kind of
of two minds about it
you know uh
on the one hand
and what I see from most people on the
right is that they are applauding this
and they're saying thank you finally
like this is what we used to do with
violent dangerous crazy people we used
to we had things called insane asylums
and that's where we put them
okay if they if if you couldn't get
through to them if they wouldn't respond
to therapy and counseling if they were
that you know off their rocker if they
were completely disconnected from
reality
um and they were a danger to themselves
or others then you had places that you
put them because what else are you
supposed to do the only other option is
to just leave them out on the street
where they're going to victimize
themselves and other people
and this used to be what we did
and um
so
on the one hand you might think it's a
good thing we're returning to that and
and it is looked at a certain way
um
because again what else are you going to
do
this this other option of just leaving
them on the street is obviously not
working
because next thing you know they're
walking down to the subway and just like
throwing a random woman in front of the
train you know these are the kind of
things that are happening
so that's
that's good if we're if we're taking
them and involuntarily hospitalizing
them
um but then on the other hand
this is New York and it's a city run by
leftists
which means that there's always even
when they appear to be doing something
good and making the right choice you
there's always going to be the the flip
side of the coin you have to worry about
in this case there's two things
number one
if you're putting cops in a position now
of
involved of taking crazy people and
involuntarily committing them that means
that uh it's involuntary so they're not
going to agree to it
right if if they were agreeing to it
then it's voluntary commitment we
already have that
the thing about violent dangerous crazy
people is that they're oftentimes not
going to they're crazy so they don't
understand they're not going to agree to
go and seek help
involuntary means that you're going in
many cases and you are
physically detaining them and against
their will bringing them to the mental
hospital
okay fine
but what happens when the cops start
using force on the crazy people
and then you've got the very helpful
crowd standing around and filming it
and then cutting it in in a way that
makes it look as brutal as possible with
as little context as possible and then
they put it on Twitter and it goes viral
and what happens then
so it's one thing to tell the police to
do this and say this is how we're going
to handle uh these sorts of people from
now on but are you going to have their
back
when we start seeing all of the the
viral videos and and the outrage and
everything else
when BLM starts Marching In the Street
about it are you going to have their
back are you going to stick by them
that's one of my first concerns first
time when I first heard this my first
thought
what happens we start seeing the videos
of this because this is not a pretty
thing okay it's not there's no easy way
to do it
as we said it's an uncomfortable reality
that you have violent dangerous crazy
people and when you're when you're
dealing with them it's not pretty it's
not going to be pretty it's going to be
a rough thing to see
and we live in a society now where we
get to see everything
so how how is that going to work that's
my concern
second concern is what counts as a
mental illness
you know
um
we know that the category of mental
illness is being increasingly expanded
every every new iteration of the
diagnostic statistical Manual of mental
disorders you know they add a bunch of
new ones
and we're already at a point where uh
any anyone I mean you could pick up the
DSM and you could find 15 mental
illnesses on there that apply to you
even if you're not crazy at all
so they this is happening within the
context of the mental Health industry
sort of uh categorizing and cataloging
and medicalizing every aspect of the
Human Condition
so as to make everybody mentally ill
even if we're not
so what counts as dangerously mentally
ill
you know do you get to a point where uh
you're is maybe just being a
conservative is a mental illness and
also a danger to the public
you tweet something that makes people
uncomfortable you tweet a criticism of
the trans Community right of the trans
agenda
we've already been told that's terrorism
that's dangerous
so you worry about these kinds of
measures being abused in that way as
well
uh what and what do we what do we end up
with like is this the right move or not
I I don't know
it's just the problem when you have
these crazy leftist running cities
there's no it's it's a no-win situation
but what I will say is in theory this is
the right approach in theory if it's
done exactly the right way and if it's
done responsibly
all right
so I've had this for a couple days I
want to play for you uh
NBC news they had this is last week they
had a story quite a tragic story about
one of the Twitter moderators who lost
his job or as they say her job
and um
is quite quite revealing to see who was
actually in charge of moderating content
who was making the calls on these things
like what count says inappropriate
content and uh here's here's one from uh
NBC watch
in her San Francisco home with some
moral support from her dog biscuit
Melissa Ingle follows the rapid fire
changes that her former employer on the
current path I just I'm really really
worried about Twitter's future on
November 12th she learned she'd been let
go first by losing access to her
accounts then an email she says other
former full-time employees have told her
they had to sign an NDA to get their
Severance benefits but because she was a
contract worker that doesn't apply to
her so she's speaking out I'm not giving
a severance package I can't they can't
take that away from me and I think
people need to know about this situation
the layoffs followed by an employee
Exodus came just days before Elon Musk
reinstated former president Donald
Trump's account Saturday evening Cal
State East Bay Professor Grant kien says
the move appears strategic and he gets
to
say that he's rescuing democracy and
reintroducing a certain type of
political discourse on Twitter
even while it overshadows for the moment
some of the really tough news that
people at Twitter have had in the past
couple of weeks while the focus might be
on Trump's account now Kian notes that
the absence of employees like Ingle who
checked content will shape users
experience on Twitter those losses of
personnel are going to be felt just over
time these things build up and the site
will become
more abusive more extreme and less
reliable over time Alyssa gourd today in
the bay look we just keep that
screenshot up there does anyone you see
that person does anyone think that that
individual
was fairly even capable of Fairly
assessing you know what qualifies as
offensive content and what doesn't
and of course when it comes to offensive
content it's it's subjective
so Twitter is run according to what that
person what offends that person
does anyone think that this could be
that that person's capable of of any
kind of like objective rational analysis
obviously not
if someone is confused about their own
identity how could they possibly be able
to do anything worthwhile when it comes
to content moderation
of course if you you know you could
simply simplify the content moderation
thing and you make it a lot easier uh
Michael Tracy tweeted this yesterday and
Elon Musk respond to it saying that it
makes sense to him and he likes it so
Michael Tracy tweeted
uh Twitter policy in 2015 and there's a
screenshot of the what the Twitter
policy was back in 2015. before media
activists lobbied for the company to
become a giant online daycare center no
direct threats of violence beyond that
Twitter doesn't mediate disputes between
users or remove offensive content if you
feel a law was broken contact police
and like I said Elon Musk responded and
said that makes sense
and it does make sense and that's what
the moderation policy really should be
it's actually pretty simple
and uh it it was simple on social media
in in the early
years of it
yeah we hear that in the the early days
of Twitter and Facebook it was like like
the wild wild west of the Internet it's
not really because in the wild wild west
you know people get shot and killed
that's not happening on the internet it
just means people can share their
opinions
and we can try to complicate it and and
uh
make it seem much more complex than it
is but there's no reason to do that
like if I'm in charge of social media
platform for me it's very simple if you
cannot directly threaten to kill people
right direct threats of violence that's
a crime that's against the law you can't
do that so
um that's out the window you cannot dox
people
and doxing means
publishing personal private information
about them like their address can't do
that then that falls under the death
threat category uh and then the only
other thing that I would add is
pornographic content starting of course
with child pornography with which Elon
Musk has already done a really good job
of getting rid of a lot of that
you know he's been able to clean almost
all that stuff out in just a few weeks
which makes you wonder about the people
that were in charge you're going back to
that Twitter moderator that we saw
if it was so easy for Elon Musk to get
rid of a lot of this the child
exploitation images
and all this stuff was able to
proliferate for years it makes it seem
like Twitter really wasn't trying that
hard to get rid of it
because at a minimum they weren't
worried about that
they were more worried about protecting
the feelings of that Twitter moderator
that we saw men who dress up like women
that was their primary concern
so child pornography obviously uh should
not be allowed and then if I were in
charge I would also include all other
forms of pornographic material as well I
wouldn't allow
but those are those are you know
definable categories pretty easy to
enforce anything outside of that
qualifies as an opinion that somebody is
sharing and you should be able to share
your opinions no matter how stupid they
may be
and if you really got into the business
of saying we're not going to allow
stupid and objectionable opinions on
this platform then almost nobody would
be allowed to post on any play it would
be a platform with nobody on it
you want a social media platform with no
stupid objection opinions then it's just
it's a platform just with nothing it's
just a blank screen and nothing is
happening
uh do we have time for this maybe we do
so uh CBS has this report actor Will
Smith says that he would understand if
audiences are not ready to see him on
the big screen so soon after the
infamous Oscar slap earlier this year on
Monday Smith spoke to Fox 5 DC's Kevin
McCarthy about his new film emancipation
which is set to be released in theaters
in December 2nd and starts streaming on
Apple TV on December 9th uh it's his
first major project since he slapped
Chris Rock on stage at the Academy
Awards and this is a movie as the title
suggests it's a movie about
slavery emancipation centers around
Smith's character Peter Peter an
enslaved man who escapes a Louisiana
Plantation and makes his way North the
film was inspired by 1863 photos of a
man whose bareback was mutilated from
whippings by his enslavers well
even before we talk about Will Smith
specifically I will say that I'm just
I'm glad we finally have a movie about
slavery
um and finally finally
Hollywood is telling this story because
I think the story has never been told
and we have we haven't heard about this
and uh it's just really good
I mean at the very least it had been 17
seconds since the last Slavery movie and
uh we know that if if we're gonna if
there's gonna be a movie about American
history
like as far as Hollywood's concerned
this is the only thing that happened in
American history
uh only certainly the only thing that
you can tell a story about
so that's great uh but Will Smith is
kind of on this
on this a publicity tour and where he's
he's claiming that I don't care you know
it's if you if I understand if you don't
if you're still upset he's pretending to
be apologetic but then if you listen to
what he's saying
it actually doesn't sound very
apologetic to me here he is with uh
Trevor Noah a couple nights ago listen
I guess what I would say
you just never know what somebody's
going through
you know you know in in the audience
right now you know you're sitting next
to uh strangers you know and
somebody's mother died last week you
know
um somebody's child is sick
you know
um somebody just lost their job
somebody just found out their spouse
cheated you know there's it's like
there's all these things and these
there's strangers and you just don't
know
what's going on with people you know and
there's I was going through something
that night you know and uh not that that
you know justifies my behavior at all I
would just say and you know you're
asking what did I learn and it's that
um
we just got to be nice to each other man
you know it's like it's hard
um I'm not justifying or excusing my
behavior
but here's my justification and my
excuse I was going through something so
this is really what he's doing he's he's
like really Will Smith is doing the
victim routine and he's making and if
you listen to him he's just making a
whole bunch of excuses I I don't even
think that he's that he's actually
apologetic at all
um
because if you're actually apologetic
you're not going to get into this I was
going through something no one gives a
damn what you were going through you got
up what you did was so
unbelievable it's like it goes beyond
inappropriate doesn't begin to cover it
okay
and yes is it was it worth the all the
headlines everything no nothing is ever
worth all the attention the media gives
to it but at the same time it's still uh
the kind of thing that yeah that's gonna
destroy your career now look look at
this way
because there is now this uh
this move online it's like this actually
seems to me I think totally there's a
lot of sympathy for for Will Smith and
people say well we should forgive him
and he's one of these putting him in the
category of these canceled he's like
he's been canceled
no this is not actually being canceled
this this in fact is just this really is
just a natural consequence for your
actions like getting banned from the
Academy Awards well you physically you
committed assault in the middle of the
ceremony of course they're going to get
banned that would happen to anybody so
just imagine if you were like what if
you were at your job and it's it's it
and you have some kind of banquet at
your job maybe an awards you know they
said like some kind of awards banquet at
your job and they're awarding employee
of the year and all these kind of things
and they bring someone up in the MC at
this uh banquet
and he makes a mild joke about you or
about your wife or something and you get
up and you physically assault the guy in
front of all your co-workers at this
employee banquet
would would you even bother begging for
your job back
like he would sit down and know okay
well I'm getting fired for that and I'm
also going to go to jail by the way
because that's a felony assault that I
just committed
and that would happen to anybody
and any normal person
so the fact that anyone's even talking
about like accepting Will Smith back
into the fold that's just privilege that
no one else would get
if that was you you're done you're fired
you're not getting another job either
when people find out about that and also
again you you are going to be criminally
prosecuted for it which he never was
so no I actually don't think that I'm
all about people make mistakes and I'm
100 against cancel culture but there is
you know not everything is cancel
culture sometimes someone just acts and
this is physical assault you committed
in the middle uh
and and sometimes it really just is a
consequence of that
all right let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeremy's razors the daily wires answer
to woke corporations is more than just
shaving now we've launched new hair body
and skin care products just in time for
the holidays but for me the most
exciting member in the new lineup of
products is Jeremy's beard kit I've been
waiting for this day to finally arrive
when all the anti-beard bigotry in this
company will come to an end and it has
because now we have the Jeremy's razors
beard kit each kit includes as you can
see right here beard oil beard balm
beard shampoo and a Bohr's hair brush to
tame your beard not your masculinity all
the products are made with natural
ingredients they're sulfate free paraben
free whatever that is woke free and
they're made in the USA so your health
and conscience will thank you all you
got to do is head over to
jeremy'srazors.com to kick woke
companies out of your bathroom get 30
off all Jeremy's products
MB says this idea that only easy lives
are worth living is paradoxically going
to bring about a pervasive misery in
society unlike anything the world has
seen before uh We've summed it up quite
well that's exactly the point I was
making in the opening yesterday it is
it's not that it's going to bring about
Misery pervasive misery and Society it
already has this myth that uh that life
is is not supposed to include suffering
that's not what life is supposed to be
and then people experience suffering
because it turns out that actually life
is suffering in many ways uh and they
experience it and then they think well
it's there's no point in living anymore
[Music]
I am
you know they think that or they think
there's something wrong with me I am
broken somehow the same that's why I'm
always talking about the way that we've
medicalized anxiety and depression
and it sends the message that people are
not supposed to
experience anxiety and so if you do then
it's it it's a sign of it's a symptom of
that something is broken in your mind
but it's actually the other way around
like
if you if you had never experienced any
anxiety at all then this is this you're
not even human like that's not that's
then that means you're not you're not a
conscious human you're not you don't
have Consciousness if you don't
experience anxiety because that's
anxiety comes with Consciousness it
comes with our awareness of ourselves
and of our uh place in the world right
and of the state of the world if you're
aware of those things it will cause
anxiety
all right
uh
let's see what wider says quoting me
suffering is a part of life like it or
not then he says yeah some people don't
like that and so they use their freedom
to choose the other option why wouldn't
they I know there were a lot of comments
like this so people anytime we talk
about euthanasia assisted suicide
whatever euphemism you want to use
there are always people say well this is
freedom it's uh Freedom it's the freedom
to destroy yourself
I think one thing we learned from that
is that's why that's why freedom freedom
freedom understood as simply the ability
to do whatever you want
that is not the be-all and end-all
and that cannot be what what our lives
revolve around and what Society revolves
around
and that kind of Freedom also doesn't
exist by the way
that that kind of Freedom cannot exist
in any society it wouldn't be us as I
wouldn't be a civilized society
obviously you're not able to do
everything that you want
um and when it comes to someone killing
themselves you know what I would ask you
and for anyone who says well this is
someone's right the right to okay well
what if you
saw you know you were you were driving
along and you and you you saw someone uh
some distraught suicidal man about to
jump off of a bridge to his death
would would you just keep driving and
say well that's his freedom it's his
choice he doesn't want to live anymore
godspeed sir wave to him as you drive by
is that what you would do
or would you stop and pull over and try
to persuade him not to jump and tell him
that life is worth living
I mean would you at a minimum call the
police as you drive by I'd hope you do
more than that but would you at a
minimum do that or would or would you
simply wave as he jumps
I think any any decent person would try
to persuade the person not to do it
because although you recognize that
someone has the freedom as it has the
physical ability to destroy themselves
you also recognize that this is not a
good choice
and that life is worth living
and the other thing about assisted
suicide too by the way is that it's it's
not we're not just talking about the
choice of the suicidal individual
we're also talking about what what the
medical profession is doing
so this is first and foremost a question
of should should the medical profession
be in the business of directly and
intentionally ending human life
should that be a treatment should the
end of human life be a treatment option
for human suffering that the medical
establishment will potentially provide
it's not a question of should people
kill themselves my answer to that is no
they should not
and I hope that would be your answer too
again if you were in a position where
you saw someone about to do it
but before we get to that question it's
really a question of should the medical
establishment be killing people
and my answer to that also is most
certainly not
all right
I cannot neglect this you all know about
the hideously stupid deal that I made
the agreement to watch a season of anime
and I've been quite worried about this
distressed about it but then
someone a valiant member of the SBG
tweeted to me this morning and this is
uh Joshua Laster he tweeted hey Matt
Walsh you're officially the star of the
shortest ever anime season one episode
16 seconds total you're welcome so
yeah this individual has created an
anime series he's completed an entire
season of this series and technically if
I watch this right now live on the air
with you then I will have fulfilled the
terms of my deal
so let's watch it
anime is Satan
[Music]
oh it says right there
I that was extraordinary I thought I
thought that was really
you know some people said if you if you
sit down and watch an anime you might
discover that you like anime and I and I
will say I don't know if I like anime in
general but that particular uh show I
found to be quite quite well it was
efficient I'll say that it was quite
efficient uh the season started a little
bit slow really picked up in the middle
I thought by the end I was worried that
at the finale it might let us down a
little bit how are they going to wrap
all the whole story together like this
and uh and they found a way to do it at
the end that I thought was was was quite
uh fantastic I just
I really I thought that was great
um and that's my that's my reaction to
it and I and so I have watched that's
that is that's a season of an anime
that's an anime season technically Okay
so
that's it the deal is complete
well the sweet baby gang came out with a
Vengeance over at uh my swag Shack this
past cyber week Johnny walrus said it's
plush companions we're flying off the
warehouse shelves but the sweet baby
album tea right with the smell of Sweet
Baby spirit and 90s Nostalgia sold out
faster than mimosas at a drag queen
brunch many of you probably weren't able
to get the shirt however because I am so
widely revealed revered for both my wild
generosity and the propensity to
Champion Equity we've decided to restock
now everyone can have another chance to
buy the gift of the year to give to
yourself or any other worthy member of
the gang so head over to my collection
overdailywire.com shop and get the sweet
baby album t-shirt or any of the other
amazing holiday offerings at the new
daily wire Plus store take advantage of
free shipping for orders over 75 and get
a free leftist tears tumbler with all
orders over 100 also last Friday we
released the first two episodes of the
brand new biblical series by Dr Jordan B
Peterson the series is called Exodus and
in it Jordan Peterson sits down on with
other Scholars to read the book of
Exodus and discuss what it means and why
it remains significant thousands of
years after it was written Scholars at
the table include Dennis Prager Jonathan
bego and many more there will be new
episodes releasing weekly and trust me
you don't want to miss the series check
out the trailer
in the beginning
created the heavens and the Earth
[Music]
turns out that a book is more durable
than than Stone it's more durable than a
castle it's more durable than an Empire
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
God is
oh do you want the Pharaoh on your side
or do you want God on your side that's
kind of the question
there's a profound sense here that what
is going on with the Israelites is the
contrast to Pharaoh right like under no
terms where you go and the Israel have
to say we will go under any terms and
we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
ethical
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny yes exactly I want
villains to get punished but do you want
the villains to learn before they have
to pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
well you got to be a member to watch so
head over to dailywire.com subscribe to
become a daily wire member and watch
Exodus today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know I actually tried to watch some
of the World Cup this week um as a
red-blooded patriotic patriotic American
it's of course my general preference to
ignore soccer and pretend it isn't real
and yet for some reason soccer continues
to insist on existing so I decided to
finally give it a fair Shake I turned on
the game or the match or the whatever
they call it and I watched as one team
kicked the ball towards the other team's
goal and then I watched as the other
team kicked it towards that team's goal
and then the team that was originally
kicking it
what happened was that they started
kicking it again and the other team they
started kicking it uh once more and and
they were kicking it back and forth at
this point I wasn't sure what the
opposing team would do would they begin
kicking the ball also again or would
something else happen and I sat in
wrapped Fascination waiting to find out
yes as it turns out they did kick it
um everyone was kicking it um they
kicked it and they kicked it and they
kicked it and I truly had never seen so
much kicking in my life and I said to
myself wow these fellas sure love to
kick all they did was kick this way in
that and at one point one of the teams I
think it was our team they kicked the
ball into the goal and this was
tremendously exciting because it was the
first time that anything actually
happened during the competition it was
also the last time because for the rest
of the match neither team would make the
mistake of doing anything interesting
again instead they would simply kick and
they would keep kicking and people in
the audience would cheer yes great job
kicking and all the kicking enthusiasts
were quite pleased with the spectacle I
cannot say that I was nearly as
satisfied I bring this up because the
daily cancellation today has to do with
soccer and I cannot in good conscience
discuss a soccer related topic without
taking time first to make fun of it so
now that I've fulfilled my duty in that
regard we have uh we have we can move on
to the topic at hand our friend our
friends speaking of kicking our friends
at outkick have the story here it is
quote the USM NT uh U.S men's team
answered the call against Iran on
Tuesday to advance to The Knockout stage
of the World Cup
for the first time since 2014. it wasn't
just a historic day for the Men's
National Team however it was a
Monumental day for the U.S wnt the
women's team by advancing to The
Knockout stage the US MNT earned a
payout of at least 13 million dollars
only half of that money will go to the
men's side while the uswnt will get the
other half the US MNT and uswnt recently
signed a new collective bargaining
agreement that states that the prize
money from the World Cups is pooled
together and split evenly between the
two teams the total prize money for the
W the 2022 World Cup in Qatar is set at
440 million dollars which is 310 million
dollars more than the women's 2019 World
Cup prize pool the usmnt will earn money
if it shocks the Netherlands on Saturday
to continue it's a World Cup dream and
the US wnt will again get half of that
number if the US MNT stuns the World Cup
and wins uh the World Cup it will earn
42 million dollars with 21 million of it
immediately going to the women's side
now in fact the women's team will earn
more money from sitting on their couches
and watching the men's team play
then they earned from winning the World
Cup themselves in 2019 and 2019. 2015
and 2019.
the bargain agreement they signed with
the men's team of course
Cuts totally in their favor so this is
not equality at all
the prize money comes from revenue
generated through TV contracts and
ticket sales and merchandise and
marketing and Licensing
the men get more prize money because
their sport earns more Revenue because
there's greater public interest in their
sport because they are better and more
impressive athletes
by soccer standards anyway
there was never any conspiracy to
deprive female soccer players of fair
compensation they just generate less
Revenue it's as simple as that
and now they're being given a cut of
Revenue they did not generate Revenue
that they lifted not a finger or a foot
to earn all in the name of equality
and I could not think of a better way
than this to reveal the fundamental
absurdity of gender equality as a
concept
because as we discover again and again
no matter how hard we try to deny it the
Sexes are not actually equal they are
different they have different capacities
different strengths and weaknesses they
thrive in different areas inequality
between the Sexes is natural it is not
then unjust
there's nothing unjust about the fact
that men have greater physical strength
than women there's nothing unjust about
the fact that women have the power to
conceive and bear children and men do
not this is simply the way it is
it's the way nature is designed
Justice is giving each giving to each
what they are due
which means that Injustice is giving to
someone what they are not do or not
giving them what they are do
but nobody can be do something that
falls outside of the natural order
injustices are perpetrated by willful
actors right nature itself cannot be
guilty of an injustice
because nature just is
it is it's it's the state of things
so if the natural inequality of the
Sexes is not unjust
then the injustices will come with our
attempts to ignore or Rectify or subvert
this natural inequality
it is not unjust that only women have
the power to give birth
but much Injustice is created when
Society pretends that men also have that
capacity
and there is nothing unjust about the
fact that men are superior athletes but
Injustice is created when a professional
sports League decides to treat men and
women as though this inequality does not
exist
and yet in this case
we are not actually going to cancel the
female soccer players for being the
recipients of this sweetheart deal
because in some ways I mean you might
even call it old-fashioned
the men are making the money and
bringing it home to the female soccer
players the men are the breadwim winners
and Megan rapino and the female soccer
players they are now like the um like
the housewives of professional sports
I might even applaud such an arrangement
if the women were holding up their end
of the bargain by doing like the men's
laundry and keeping their houses in
order
but they are required to do nothing
which again is what makes this unjust
and yet who can blame them for taking
the deal
I mean if if I could get the soccer team
to split their earnings with me
I'd take the money it's not fair but
like if they would agree to it I would
take it
no the group that really deserves to be
canceled is the men's team
because they agreed to this arrangement
because they were afraid to say no
and they were too intent on virtue
signaling too fearful of of upsetting
the feminists that they uh you know they
weren't upset so they signed the
collective bargaining agreement to
Forfeit half of their own money and and
give it to the least sympathetic and
needy charity in the world
known as women's soccer
the men's team they even pretended to be
excited when this deal was signed
several months ago a lot of the men's
soccer players they were like cheering
it on yay they cheered on their own
robbery they got mugged by Megan Rapinoe
in a back alley and they responded by
hailing her heroism and courage
the women's team doesn't deserve the
windfall that they will now receive but
the men's team
certainly does deserve to be on the
losing end it is a fitting penalty for
their cowardice
and so they are the ones who are today
canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the shows and move over to
the members blog hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign